hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen with somewhere in full
swing I've been drinking camping
swimming and just enjoying every
possible moment outside or hit with
another apocalyptic winter as much as I
love this warm weather the elements are
not always kind but thankfully since we
have so much fun with our spring diy
beauty hacks we're going back hatch out
with some more homemade remedies this
time we're battling all your summer
Beauty problems with ingredients you
probably have kicking around in your
house first let's deep frist at
community hair you know how it is you
spent two hours curling your hair and
the moment you step out into that
humidity it looks like you're wearing a
clown wig ditch the frizz with my
homemade avocado and olive oil hair mask
packed with reparative oils and vitamin
E on these together one avocado with two
tablespoons of extra virgin olive oil
comb it through my hair and then let it
sit for 30 minutes before washing and
drying as usual next let's do that
sender while you should never substitute
anything for your regular use of
sunscreen green tea contains
antioxidants like catechins and cannons
and early research suggests that it may
have some UV protective india team flama
tory benefit if you know you're heading
out to the sun drinking a few cups of
ice cream tea will help you load up on
extra antioxidants while putting some so
green tea bags on your burn as a cool
progress may give you some relief third
help that hangover or heat stroke
whether you've had one too many drinks
or the heat is starting to get to you
hydration is totally key it's
recommended that most women get around
2.2 liters of water a day and then
three liters a day but you always always
always want to listen to your body for
those early signs of dehydration to let
you know when you need more signs like
dry mouth dark yellow pee and person or
all telltale signs that you need to pack
your water game accordingly one of my
favorite ways to get in my aged well
week I would have feeling like a chore
it's with my SodaStream sparkling water
maker because you can customize the
level of carbonation you use and even
flavor it naturally things like fruit
veggies citrus and herbs my go-to
combination is my house made sparkling
water some model raspberries lemon and
basil trust me no one's going to be
getting dehydrated or hungover when
you're sporting a trip like this and
finally relieved those itchy bug bites
or poison ivy nothing ruins a cute
outfit like an itchy red rash so if you
stumbled into a better poison ivy or the
skiers even alive just know you've got a
big bag of oatmeal waiting for you at
home I take a cup of rolled oats and
process them in a food processor until
they turn into a powder and then I add
them along with two cups of whole milk
to a tepid bath hop in for a relaxing
hour with a good book or magazine for
gently pat yourself dry so there you
have it for easy DIY Beauty hats to help
you get the most out of this beautiful
summer weather thanks so much for
watching for more great DIY ideas be
sure to subscribe to my channel and I'll
see you next time
a nice kitchen today we're going to be
talking about antioxidants we hear the
word all the time we know we should be
getting more of them but why are they
even important anyway although give you
the old bio chemistry textbook
definition antioxidants are substances
that camera of the processes of an
oxidation in the body and too much
oxidation is values there